uh girl where are your pants it's a
dress nope not today absolutely not you
are half-naked yes go am i serious yes
go back in there and shoot sorry that's
not gonna work I'm gonna be late I don't
care if you're gonna be late go back in
that room and change not today huh I
don't know what you think this is who do
you think you're talking to
do I look like one of your friends do
you think I'm just made of money do you
hear me talking to you I didn't think
you were actually talking oh yeah now
you're getting smart with me oh you are
trying me today wearing osakan pants got
your blood all hanging out I don't think
so are you serious like I'm serious go
go back and I room and go change not
today honey
I left your mail on the table okay mom
really
too busy to answer my calls huh Oh mom
so who are you talking to
it better not be no boy - yeah - uh yeah
yeah can you get the chicken out the
freezer for me that's what we're gonna
have for dinner tonight
but you're right here are you getting
smart with me
no ain't nobody paying for no cell phone
so you can talk to no boys so I really
want you to meet my friend Taylor okay
don't Taylor Rebecca Smith me Mom just
shut up just shut the [ __ ] up is that
your friend no god I would never be
friends with someone who talks to their
mom like that let her see you but look I
don't know her are you
no no no you must think I'm stupid this
is just to think I'm crazy I know you at
that boy's house I know you at that are
you laughing about something cuz I got
something for you too you just hold on
for a minute
where are you it's gonna be you on there
one day